The Joe Rogan experience,
you know,
you know those storage wars shows,
I guess some of them may fake.
Yeah,
they do.
They set them up.
They load up the storage and they ought to believe we found a world war two
helmet.
It's Elvis.
His underwear was unbelievable.
Yeah,
they used to be real.
Actually a few of them were very real and then they got caught online.
A bunch of people online,
we're calling them out being like,
this is bullshit.
This is fake.
I saw them setting it up like they got,
they got caught,
but that's,
they're going to do that.
They should find magic in there and say he's fine.
He's definitely shit storage wars where they,
they go in there and they find a Leprechaun.
[inaudible] makes one huge disappear.
Yeah.
One person disappears and they have a genie in a lamp and it's gotta be worth
treating me like I'm really stupid.
Have you ever watched the show ghost hunters?
Do you know who are ghost adventures?
Do you know this guy dude,
Zach bag.
Is Zak Bagans?
Do you know this guy?
I do not know him personally.
He makes me laugh so fucking hard because they've done like nine seasons now.
I don't even know how many of the things I found any ghost.
Come on,
man.
They have all this great technology now that's approved that he believes in
ghosts.
Here's the best part.
Okay.
He is all in,
right.
Which I love anybody that's all in whatever they're doing to have to be.
The host does all his adventure,
but also now he's super self aware of their popularity and of his character
caricature of himself.
So he does it now on purpose.
He took off his shirt when episode and he goes,
you want to fucking fight me ghost?
Let's fucking go dude.
Toe Up,
throw a fucking punch.
You're like,
he's aware of his character that is this broey ghost fist fighter.
This dude is Brenton shop.
Shabu shop sign episode.
Looking at him.
He looks like he just got along time.
Shane car would sparring sessions.
Yeah,
he's still in the fight and he's still out of it.
And is it Zach with the beard?
No.
No,
Zack is that dude right there.
Right.
So Zack,
where's,
um,
ed hardy type of shirts,
right?
He wears these loud,
ridiculous,
he battered shirts,
but he's,
you got to see it doing more newer episodes to do something from like 2009 to
18.
You'll see what he looks like now.
He's gotten way more fucking jacked.
His hair,
his hair is all flaked up.
You know,
he's gotten like more tan around and shit.
He's become,
do you think this becomes super self aware?
Did he believes in ghosts?
No,
I think he's just self aware of the product he's created really,
that he understands now that's a challenge.
I see the next whiskey ginger podcast,
you,
me and Zack,
Zack,
Zack.
That's him right there.
Right?
Like now he's like Holly,
he looks like a Hollywood guy.
Like he's got these big black frame glasses.
Funny.
Like you can't,
he can't look any better.
You know,
you're not allowing him to have better style when Hollywood,
you're so,
Chicago's fucking good as fucking Hollywood.
This spiky hair.
He went in Hollywood the fall.
I'll tell you.
That's the one thing I know I won't do is uh,
I'll never get to a place when I'll be wearing clothes where I used to make fun
of them like that.
Like I remember going,
sky's wearing a fucking $900 tee shirt.
I know now I can't do that.
Like I,
I can't,
I can't get,
I can't do that now cause I used to shit on it so much.
Yeah.
You have to mind by the rules of your own [inaudible].
If I pushed it out there for so long,
let's say he's got a nice hats him.
Yeah,
it looks good.
Right?
Has had Jamie's that your buddy and say the most recent photo I could find
Jamie.
That's,
do I zoom in real quick?
I thought you were trying to say something.
Is he handsome fellow?
Cute Guy.
Jamie,
I want you to grow your facial hair just like that.
You really think,
do you really think he doesn't believe in ghosts?
I think he does not believe in ghosts.
I think he,
I think he loves the paranormal,
right?
He loves the idea of the paranormal.
I think he loves the idea of forces at nature happening molecules,
energies around us,
all influencing the way we act.
Sure.
I don't think he believes in actual apparitions or what do they call them?
S uh,
uh,
spirits on his EVP.
We felt the spirit,
they'll do this thing where they'll see a little orb or a light.
This happens all the time with cameras when you switch to night vision and not
these little flecks of dusk kind of reflect light off the lenses.
And he'll go,
it's an orb.
And they'll,
you know,
watch it float through the lens and he's,
he is obsessed about these orbs.
They enter the orb and he does this voiceover shit.
You got lots of fucking jail.
I get hired.
I watch it.
It's maybe one of my favorite things.
What's Jamie?
You're a photographer.
What's the,
um,
scientific explanation for those little balls that show up in photographs?
What is it?
I don't have the knowledge for that,
but it can be explained lots of different ways.
It's mostly,
it probably like a light flare of some kind to sprouts cause there's just like
close.
But believer you stammered through that.
So bad.
Just continued.
I'm terrible fucking jobs sound like tography science.
But like in this lens here there's like five different pieces of glass.
So there's just at whatever angle you're holding it,
depending on where the light source is coming from,
it might create an artifact,
which would be a little circle.
So if you're dealing with a really nice camera like that one,
but what about like with one of them bullshit w w one of those zip in a shoot
ones.
Then they're using
it,
but that that's like less.
Uh,
there's why there would be some on that is probably because it's less,
it's less good.
It's,
it's has less,
not the right word,
but a less technology in there.
I don't know.
I can't explain it honestly.
Trines we should Google it because orb lovers right now are freaking out.
Oh my God.
There are angels
gift.
Anytime it or passes near a human,
he'll go watch chose reaction as the orb goes behind his head.
Yeah.
And your change your eyes,
the eyes will change.
It was amazing.
Don't believe in fucking ghosts.
I believe in every,
you don't believe in guns all in with everything.
Fuck that foot back.
Scatter to fuck up.
What's that?
Here you go.
Back scatter back scatter.
The artifact can result from the backscatter or retro reflection of light from
airborne solid particles such as dust or part of that I solid or liquid
droplets,
especially rain or mist can also be caused by foreign material within the
camera's Lens.
So these dots are blurred images of dust particles am night Shama Lama Ding Dong
should make a movie in that movie and it should be called back scanner.
Call him that anymore.
That's really rude.
Is it though?
It's kind of funny and it's Shama Milan.
That's his fucking name.
Mama [inaudible] you turn on and you started it.
You fucking put it on me.
What are you racist?
What's wrong with you man?
He makes them good goddamn movies.
The guy,
he takes some crazy risks.
But uh,
I love the sixth sense.
That was a great fuck.
Come on.
Every,
I love the village.
People didn't like that.
I didn't see a,
I thought the village,
the end of it,
I was like,
well,
what about planes?
Like they,
they,
they don't,
they don't show any planes going over how big it would have to be to avoid all
the planes.
Well,
they have to be a shepherd point.
Fuck them.
Nobody.
Places where no planes promote because they made it out to the road and then
instantly the guy to the road and people are like,
hey car.
Like what car?
Woo.
18 hundreds that like Saint Louis is like right there.
You know what I liked though?
Ghost.
No Devil.
The one was in the elevator.
That was a good one.
Yeah,
that was good.
Those good?
That's good.
Well,
he takes chances.
He takes a shower like.